good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday if you
could call it that but you can't like
most americans you're probably still
trying to digest what has happened over
these past four days profound national
trauma is like that once you face
something unimaginably horrible
nothing is ever the same nothing will
ever be the same like prison it changes
a man this is not an easy time for any
of us we get it we're literally
literally still shaking as we think
about how close this country came to
losing our democracy last thursday
last thursday was june 16th
a day forever branded in our memory a
day that has joined the pantheon of
tragic turning points in human history
where were you on 6 16 you'll never
forget and neither will we
at the time we were preparing a show on
tony fauci and his push for a new corona
shot for kids it seemed important then
it seems so trivial now as we were
speaking on the air at that very moment
a team of seven saboteurs had entered
the capitol grounds and then proceeded
as saboteurs do to breach the capital
itself
inside those hallowed grounds within the
very womb of democracy these wreckers
began their hunt for sitting members of
congress that happened ladies and
gentlemen and if it sounds shocking to
you it gets more harrowing from there
this was not some spontaneous outbreak
of insurrection no
this was a meticulously planned coup
from afar
the group in the capital was under the
direct control of an extremist
called stephen colbert who was a white
man is by definition a white extremist
this white extremist stephen colbert had
a fifth column within the capital to
help him
pull off his diabolical plan he had
members of congress in his employ
members of congress who believe it or
not helped the insurrectionists enter
the capitol just open the doors and let
them walk in
yes that can happen
and that fifth column included adam
schiff of california stephanie murphy of
florida and a new member called jake
auchenkloss of massachusetts besmirching
his family name
those three members of congress allowed
the wreckers inside the longworth house
office building
while inside the insurrection has tried
to gain access to a restricted area
but they were thwarted by brave law
enforcement who arrived
risking their very lives to remove the
insurrections from the premises
but it wasn't enough because hours later
an aide to congressman awkinclaw
secretly permitted the insurrections to
re-enter the capital complex
and then around 8 30 p.m they caused
some kind of disturbance the details are
murky as of tonight but according to one
report they were banging on windows
inside the capitol trashing the place
committing violence against our
democracy
and for that apparently we are hearing
tonight
they were put in jail
but within hours they were out again
now the man who controlled this
attempted to coup stephen colbert knew
exactly what he was doing he knew the
stakes he knew the crimes he was
committing and we know that because just
last year
this white extremist stephen colbert
explained that grown men who unlawfully
enter the capital to harass sitting
members of congress
are not pranksters they're not
protesters
they're domestic terrorists
lord have mercy there are some dark
subjects
that we talk about on the show
occasionally but
i've rarely been as upset
as i am tonight
this is the most shocking most tragic
least surprising thing i've ever seen
and his followers did what he told them
to do behave in a way that's what's the
word
deplorable one of these domestic
terrorists even broke into speaker
pelosi's office and put his feet up on
her desk they now live in an alternate
universe that is now collapsing in on
itself it's it's it's like a black hole
of whiteness and this was never some
sort of peaceful protest this was
charlottesville come home to roost
oh
it's shocking
these are domestic terrorists
stephen colbert in what
the literary community refers to as
foreshadowing described his own coup
and yet stephen colbert somehow still
has access to the airwaves and to
digital media spreading his hate
unfettered convincing future generations
of insurrections to do what his team of
savateurs did last week that must stop
people who plan coups must be silenced
there's recent precedent for that and
anyone who disagrees should be
disconnected from amazon web services
immediately
no spreading hate
but stopping white extremist stephen
colbert from
passing on his message of insurrection
to the country won't solve what the rest
of us are living with and that's trauma
and like all trauma
journalists are affected
most profoundly we're scarred by what we
saw we're all casey hunt tonight it'll
be a long time before we can revisit the
capitol building before we can forget
where we were when democracy shook on
its very foundations it's going to take
therapy it's going to take a lot of
support from our fellow survivors before
we can recapture the carefree innocence
that stephen colbert stole from us
before we can feel safe again
we're not alone in our despair tonight
lies that would bring thousands of angry
people to the capitol for one of
america's darkest days became one of the
darkest days in american political
history very next day was one of the
darkest days in this nation's history to
one of the most dramatic and dark days
in american history one of the darkest
days in u.s history this was one of the
darkest days in american history what
size bottle of bourbon do you drink at
night to forget your central role in the
darkest day in our capital's history
yeah
yeah journalists feel this stuff deeply
people say oh you're just robots just
automatons in nerd hardened callous to
the news you don't feel
but we do
we do feel
you see something like that
you see an insurrection take place
before your very eyes
and it hurts you it changes you you're
not the same person how long will it
take to heal
it's impossible to know
cnn just interviewed a rolling stone
journalist who after a year and a half
after the last insurrection still hasn't
healed watch
grace you wrote for poynter at the end
of january last year you said sometimes
i'm fine sometimes i want to sob for
hours sometimes i just want to sleep so
that sounds to me like trauma that
sounds like ptsd
do you feel like you still experience
that
i do think so to a certain extent this
morning when i got on the train to come
down here and see you brian i was
looking at the capitol dope right and
you know my parents recently came down
to visit me and we were near it and i
remember thinking to myself man i can't
wait until i can look at this
and not feel sad
now you look at something like that and
you're tempted to dismiss it out of hand
oh you're having trouble sleeping you
sob for no reason well that's because
you have a barren personal life your
celibate your only meaningful human
contact comes from the ubereats guy you
live out your emotional life on netflix
that's your core problem it couldn't
really be an insurrection that made you
cry sorry excuse me sorry stop
disrupted your sleep
but it can
for a journalist this stuff hurts
but if you think it's bad for us in the
news media
what do you think it was like for the
lawmakers who were trapped inside
thursday night
in the last insurrection even though she
was nowhere near the capital
she's probably getting her nails done
but it didn't matter sandy cortez nearly
died
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
has given a harrowing account of her
experience on january 6. a harrowing and
emotional account of what happened to
her during the capital riot it's one of
the most harrowing accounts so far
congresswoman alexander ocasio-cortez
tell that harrowing story the harrowing
story of how she hid from attackers
during the capital riot
disclosing new harrowing details
that's what an insurrection looks like
but there's no
charade-like miming
that can ever fully express the pain
inside
we're going to deal with that in our
quiet alone time possibly wearing an
upscale turtleneck we'll let you know
but the question is
once we've had an act of war like this
how does the country respond how do we
all respond
boom boom boom as sandy would say
obviously we need a commission of course
and a criminal investigation there's
probably one underway by the way and
then a day of remembrance because you
can't let the memory die so who's going
to lead this well the obvious candidates
liz cheney
adam schiff and speaking of crying adam
kinzinger
they're the naturals
we called them today to see what they're
planning how are we going to commemorate
this latest insurrection they haven't
gotten back to us yet probably sleeping
or weeping
but we can assume from past experience
that adam kinziger feels this really
deeply really deeply watch talk about
the impact of that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies
are not defined
by our bad days
yeah
adam kinzinger is right and we've made
fun of him in the past like a grown dude
crying on tv we mocked that we apologize
adam kinzinger
we can recover
but there's really only one path toward
recovery if you talk to any recovery
expert they will tell you the way to
recover
is to viciously punish the people who
hurt your feelings
step one that's always step one
so we're going to have to meet out some
pretty serious punishment stephen's
colbert's team of insurrectionists have
been jailed for one night that's not a
lot the penalty for insurrection is
death
we're not calling for that here this is
a moderate show these are our fellow
americans we owe them a second chance
thankfully there's recent precedent to
help guide an appropriate punishment
what is the right punishment for
insurrection
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight